another part that you write about with
the Three Musketeers and the whole
engineering the firing and the bringing
in the engineers to try to sort of go
hardcore so there's a lot of interesting
sort of questions to ask there but the
high level can you just comment about
that
part of the Saga which is
bringing in the engineers and seeing
like what can we do here right he
brought in the engineers and figured
that the amount of people doing Tesla
full self-driving autopilot and all the
software there was about one tenth of
what was doing software for Twitter and
he said this can't be the case
and he fired 85 percent in three
different rounds the first was
just firing people because they looked
at the coding and they had a team of
people from Tesla's autopilot team
grading the codes of ever of all that
was written in the past year or so
then he fired people you know who didn't
seem to be totally all in or loyal and
then another round of layoffs so
uh
at each step of the way almost everybody
says that's enough it's going to destroy
things yeah uh from Alex Sparrow his
lawyer to Jared virtual he's like whoa
whoa whoa you know and even Andrew and
James the young cousins who are tasked
with making a list and figuring out
who's good or bad same we've done enough
we're going to be in real trouble
and they were partly right I mean there
was degradation of the service some
but not as much as half the services I
use half the time you know and
I wake up each morning and
hit the app and okay still there what do
you think was that too much I think that
he has an algorithm that we mentioned
earlier that begins with question every
requirement what it's up to is delete
delete delete
every point and then a corollary to that
is if you don't end up adding back 20 of
what you deleted then you didn't delete
enough in the first round because you
were too timid well so you asked me did
he overdo it he probably overdid it by
20 which is his formula and they're
probably trying to hire people now to
keep things going
but it sends a strong signal
to people that are hired back or the
people that are still there the the API
and what Steve Jobs and many other great
leaders felt and certainly Bezos and
certainly
in the early days of Microsoft Bill
Gates he was Hardcore only a players
so how much of Elon success would you
say elon's and uh Steve Jobs's success
is the hiring and managing of great
teams when I asked Steve Jobs at one
point what was the best product you ever
created
I thought he'd say maybe the Macintosh
or maybe the iPhone
he said no those products are hard the
best thing I ever created was the team
that made those products and that's the
hard part is creating a team and he did
you know from Johnny Ive to Tim Cook and
at EQ and Phil Schiller
Elon has done a good job bringing in
people Glenn Shotwell obviously
Linda yagarino she's you know can
navigate through the current crises
uh certainly
Stellar people at SpaceX like Martin
Cosa and then at Tesla like Drew
backlino and Lars maravi and Tom Zhu and
many others
um he's not as much of a team
collaborator essay Benjamin Franklin who
by the way that's the best team ever
created which is the founders and you
had to have really smart people like
Jefferson and Madison and really
passionate people like John Adams and
his cousin Samuel and really a guy of
high rectitude like Washington but you
also needed a Ben Franklin who could
bring everybody together and Forge A
team out of them and make them
compromise with each other
musk is a magnet for awesome Talent
magnet interesting but there's the
there's like the priorities of hiring of
um
based on Excellence trustworthiness and
drive these are things you've described
throughout the book I mean there there's
a pretty
uh concrete and rigorous
set of ideas based on which the hiring
is done oh yeah and he has a very good
Spidey uh intuitive sense just looking
at people
who could maybe not looking at them but
studying them who could be good one of
his uh uh
ways of operating
is what he calls a skip level meeting
and let's take a very specific thing
like the Raptor engine which is powering
the um Starship and it wasn't going well
it looked like a spaghetti Bush and it
was going to be hard to manufacture and
he got rid of the people
who were in charge of that team and now
remember that he spent a couple of
months doing what he called skip level
which means instead of meeting with his
direct reports on the Raptor team he
would meet with the people one level
below them and so he would skip a level
and meet with them and he said this is
and I just asked him what they're doing
and I drill them with questions and he
said this is how I figure out who's
going to emerge he said it was
particularly difficult I was sitting in
those meetings because people were
wearing masks it was doing the height of
covid uh and he said it made it a little
bit harder for him because he has to get
the input but I watched as a young kid
dreadlocks named Jacob McKenzie he's in
the book
is sitting there and he's a bit like you
engineering mindset speaks in a bit of a
monotone musk would ask a question and
he would give an answer and the answer
would be very straightforward and he
didn't you know get rattled he was like
this
it must said one day called him up at
three well I won't say 3 A.M but after
midnight said you still around yeah Jake
said yeah I'm still at work and he said
okay I'm Gonna Make You in charge of the
team building Raptor
and that was like a big surprise but
Jacob McKenzie has now gotten a version
of raptor and when they're building him
at least one a week and they're pretty
awesome and
um that's where his talent must Talent
for
finding the right person and promoting
them that's where it is and promoting it
in a way where it's like here's the ball
here catch yeah yeah and you run with it
I have I've interacted with quite a few
uh folks from even just the model X the
the all throughout where people you know
on paper don't seem like they would be
able to run the thing and they run it
extremely successfully and he does it
wrong sometimes he's had a horrible
track record with the solo roof division
wonderful guy named Brian Dow I really
liked him uh and when they were doing
the battery Factory surge in Nevada
uh musk got rid of two or three people
and there's Brian Dow can do can do can
do stays up all night and he gets
promoted and runs it and so finally goes
uh musk goes through two or three people
running the solo roof division finally
calls up Brian down I was sitting in
Moss house in Boca Chica that little
tiny two-bedroom he has and he offers
Brian Dow the job of running solar roof
and you know buying their okay can do
can do and two or three times musk
insisted that they put install a solo
roof in one of those houses in Boca
Chica this is this tiny village at the
south end of Texas
and late at night I mean I'd have to
climb up to the top of the roof on these
ladders and stand on this peaked roof as
musk is there saying why do we need four
screws to put in this single leg and and
Brian was just sweating and doing
everything but then after a couple of
months it wasn't going well and boom
uh musk just fired him
so I always try to learn what is it that
makes those who stay thrive
what's the lesson there what do you
think well I think it's self-knowledge
like an Andy Krebs or others they say uh
I am hardcore I really want to get a
rocket to Mars and that's more important
than anything else
uh one of the people I think it's I
think it's Tim Zaman I hope uh when he
hears this I'm getting him the right
person who you know took time it was
working for Tesla autopilot and it was
just so intense he took some time off
and and then went to another company he
said I was burned out at Tesla but then
I was bored at the next place so I
called I think it was Ashok it I said
can I come back he said sure he said
I've learned about myself I'd rather be
burned out than born that's a good line
um well can you just uh Linger on one of
the three that seemed interesting to you
in in terms of Excellence
trustworthiness and drive which one do
you think is is the most important and
the hardest to get at the
trustworthiness is an interesting one
like are you ride or die kind of thing
yeah I think that especially when it
came to taking over Twitter he thought
half the people there were disloyal and
he was wrong about two-thirds were
disloyal not just that
and it was how do we weed out those and
he did something and made um the firing
squad I call it or the Musketeers I
think is my nickname for them which is
you know the young cousins and two or
three other people he made them look at
the slack messages these people had post
everybody at Twitter and posted and they
went through hundreds of slack messages
so if anybody
posted on the internal Slack
you know that jerk Elon Musk is going to
take over and I'm afraid that he's a
maniac or something
they would be on the list because they
want all in loyal uh they did not look
at private slack messages and I guess
people who are posting on a corporate
slack board should be aware that your
company can look at them but that's more
than I would have done or most people
would have done
and so that was to figure out who's
deeply committed and loyal I think that
was mainly the case at Twitter he
doesn't sit around it SpaceX saying
who's loyal to me at
um other places
it's excellent but that's pretty well a
given everybody is like a mark jankosa
just whip smart it's all you hardcore
and all in especially if you have to
move to this spit of a town in the South
Tip of Texas called Boca Chica
you know you got to be all in yeah yeah
and that's the drive the the last piece